hi my name is you I'm a PhD candidate in
the Department of Anthropology here at
Yale it's my pleasure to introduce and
moderate this panel on Imperial swine
and settler colonialism will have we are
delighted to have all three historians
on this panel our first speaker would be
Marcy Norton Marcy is associate
professor of history at George
Washington University and the author of
sacred gifts profane pleasures a history
of tobacco and chocolate in the Atlantic
world our second speaker would be Robin
Derby Robin is associate professor of
Latin American history at the University
of California Los Angeles her current
book project trees demonic animal
apparitions in haiti and the dominican
republic and is entitled feta bestia
sorcery as history in the haitian
dominican borderlands thank you
um so let me begin by thanking Gabe and
Jim and Alden for their effort and their
imagination and putting together such a
marvelous conference and everyone else
who has helped make this possible and
the fabulous papers that I've heard so
far so there was no way that I couldn't
begin my contribution about pigs without
talking about what for me is probably
the most arresting evidence I found
during my research on human animal
relationships on both sides of the
Atlantic world beginning in 1492 this
tale of three pigs was interspersed in
the account of the conquistador turned
chronicler gonzalo fernandez tovia those
a description of a maroon rebellion and
then suppression of it in nville island
of Hispaniola and we are Hispaniola and
so in 1543 a group of spanish soldiers
were pursuing the maroon rebels in seba
mountain region in what is today the
Dominican Republic when they came across
three pigs Oh viedo didn't write this
but it wouldn't be surprising if the
pigs approached the soldiers with gentle
curiosity whatever their demeanor the
soldiers killed them as they would have
any of the numerous feral pigs roaming
in the countryside here is where we are
however the Spanish men soon discovered
that the pigs had a human companion who
was greatly bereaved at their loss this
man and I now have reason to think that
he would have been native to northern
South America and enslaved as part of
the exponentially increasing slave trade
indigenous slave trade in this period
though in a recent article identified
him as Taino but I think that's now
wrong alviero explained that this Indian
had survived in the wilderness through
special relationship with the three
formerly feral pigs two males and a
female the man and his pigs would go
hunting for wild pigs and the way that
Europeans had to pray with dogs
um where one pig would track the other
one would cease and one would assist and
the man would give the final thrust of
death with a make-do spear contemporary
and then preside over the ritual
distribution of the carcass as was done
in traditional European hunts in Europe
and ova 2 explained that when there
wasn't available pray he would make a
barbecue for himself or he would he
would after when there was pray they
would barbecue for himself and salt the
flesh for several days consumptions when
prey was not readily available the man
forged for roots and plants which he ate
and shared with his porcine company at
nitro ova though the said Indian went to
bed among that best you'll company
petting for hours one and then the other
devoted to the swine lap or sesa after
seeing his beloved pigs slaughtered the
man lamented to the three soldiers
according to ova though he said those
pigs gave me life and maintained me as I
maintain them they were my friends and
good company when I gave this name the
other was called section such and the
female pig was called so-and-so
reflecting on this episode of elo was
amazed by this what he called this great
novelty in which pigs being hunted were
converted into being hunters and he
credited the Indian being a rational
animal and a human man with ingenuity
for teaching those beasts and hunting
bringing a trainable friendship to that
occupation and convincing his pigs to
kill others they came across because
their master did not have love for these
others yet he was also scornful the
choice to flee from men and be content
living with beasts and beam bestial a
conventional reading might be to suggest
that ova de was revealing the
anthropocentrism typical of europeans of
his age and that the Indians closeness
to the pigs challenged the European
sense of hierarchy in which men should
stand separate and above animals but I
would like to propose instead that
Oviedo's interests and confusion and
reaction was a base in the fact that for
him the
episode was notable notable because it
produced confusion between caturah
categories generated by modes of
interaction of husbandry and hunting I
define a mode of interaction as a
structure comprised of entrenched
customs patterns and behaviors and
institutions that organized how people
relate to and think about animals over
the long DeRay and most importantly for
today's talk produce the possibilities
or lack thereof for interspecies
intercept activity modes of interaction
are ontologically productive engendering
taxonomy xand knowledge and refract and
reinforce other organizing structures
class relationships economic
institutions patriarchy I will
necessarily be brief and schematic in
this presentation but I developed this
framework more fully in some of these
publications the deep histories that
explain both Oviedo's reaction to this
episode and the behaviors and views of
the indian man require an understanding
of both European and lowland South
American modes of interaction and Europe
at least since the High Middle Ages
these two structures are hunting and
husbandry which coexisted and influenced
each other but were opposed in the kinds
of interspecies intersubjectivity zeeeee
they produced an indigenous lowland
South America which from a cultural
vantage point included the islands of
the Caribbean the complementary
structures were to use the terminology
preferred by anthropologists of
contemporary South America predation and
familiarization at least prior to
European acculturation so first let's
use Oviedo's anecdote as an entree into
understanding early modern Spanish and
more broadly European human Pig
relationships a quintessentially noble
activity hunting was conceived of as a
form of practice and proxy for war
integral to the tactics and ideologies
of the ruling elite bolstering
legitimating and naturalizing neo feudal
hegemony hunting was so ennobling that
commoner hunters employed in rural hunts
were given the privileges of the gentry
the hunt produced three categories of
actors the chief Huntsman vassals and
pray here are some vassal animals among
these vassals were
tional huntsmen gamesman kennel masters
falconers and animal vassals who were
carefully bred horses and dogs and tamed
Raptors who worked in falconry the
prestige of animal vassals dwarf that of
many humans as did their superior diets
and there was a prescription against
eating vassal animals even if their
relatives and husbandry could and would
be killed for consumption the other
category in the hunting mode of
interaction was the enemy or the prey of
whom the wild boar was the most
prestigious type in medieval and early
modern Spain and in many other parts of
Europe the nobility figured as owners of
large flocks and rentiers profited from
taxes and tithes that were among the
fruits of the livestock economy
livestock husbandry belonged to the
realm of the plebeian whereas hunters
and professional falconers and kennel
masters were symbolically and sometimes
diretta kaliya noble by their
relationships with vassal animals
dominant opinion considered those who
work most closely with animals and
husbandry as degraded by the
relationship humanist pastoralism
notwithstanding shepherds along with
others whose bodies were in close
proximity to livestock animals muleteers
butchers Tanner's peasants in general
were figures of derision among elites
and I would argue that some of these
attitudes were internalized within
peasant communities husbandry produced
three categories of animals livestock
servants such as oxen and shepherd dogs
and vermin such as sheep killing wolves
but I will focus on the first category
livestock or in Spanish ganado which
comprised the majority of animals living
emits human society the livestock
section of gabriela alonso de travis
much reprinted libro de agricultura from
the 16th century offers a hierarchy
among the herd animals at the bottom
where goats and pigs were the second to
last to illustrate the differences in
intersubjectivity produced by hunting
and husbandry i'm going to give you an
example from a 17th century hunting
manual written by someone who became the
chief Huntsman for Philip the third but
whose reminisce came from his time when
he served the Marquis of en avoir VNL
weather in the eastern part of Spain in
extremadura in the 1620s the Viet the
Marquis lands included dense forests
little alleys of
streams and slices of pasture land where
there lived herd of about 15 or 20 wild
boar sows and there are 30 or so young
the Huntsman identified one of the one
of these sows as their leader or ghia
and wrote that she seemed to have quote
reason and understanding because she did
things that shocked all of us seemingly
against nature he recounted how the
board had lived and and her her group
had lived many months even years without
anyone being able to kill any of them
they maintained their safety by ensuring
that dogs and these are his words could
not catch their scent taking care to
move with the wind in their face without
taking a step or a path unless the wind
was against them the leader also
protected the others while they wild wad
by circling around the mud hole he wrote
that the sow and his words made a fool
of him on many occasions until finally
his scent dog led him to a spot where he
could stake out at night and he wrote
quote his legs and arms trembling from
desire and the bright moonlight he shot
the powerful sow afterwards quote the
others the other board not having a
leader stopped in the dense forests
waiting for their arrival of their now
dead leader and then I could hear them
he wrote morning and urging one or the
other that she would take over and lead
when he saw the sows corpse he found a
large and fat animal with an ear pierced
by two bullets and surmised her earlier
escape from death quote was the reason
that she lived with so much care I
should mention that this is just one of
any number of reminiscences about
Northey boars but their incidents isn't
because he had a good luck of coming
across special Seward's but because the
practice is engendered by hunting
created these opportunities for what I
call deep observation and even included
sympathetic mimesis as the hunter
matched his breath to that of the boar
he was stalking this recollection
illustrates characteristics of
intersubjectivity of hunter prey
relationships the recognition of
individuality the identification was
pray and a dynamic of engagement by
contrast where hunting animals were
appreciated for their individuality
livestock creatures were viewed as units
of a collective for instance in the
english treatise government of cattle it
is advised that quote among a herd of
many pigs you must have diverse and
sundry marks to know which is which for
else it will trouble his wits to know
one from the other and it's estimated
that 80 to a hundred thousand haads were
farmed in oak forest in the betta host
region and individual herds could
average around 600 in Spain and if
you're wondering well this would be
different if you were a peasant in fact
usually in village communities there
would be a swineherd who would be
responsible for taking care of
individual peasant families herds for
the day so this kind of logic of the
herd extended across different kinds of
husbandry arrangements second we're
hunting animals were seen as subjects
with whom collaboration or competition
was taken for granted ganado or herd
animals were objects be managed the
passive recipients of breeding feeding
fattening curing shearing and
slaughtering and to save on time I won't
give you too many examples of this but
the discourse that we've been hearing I
think survives very much into the
present and they have very clear
antecedents in this period if not
earlier and third the practices and
ideology that comprised that
aristocratic hunt produced
identification between 104 whereas
alienation was central to relations with
livestock the living livestock a
creature was figured as existing in a
transitional state that would culminate
in its death or the dispossession of its
body parts an alienation the emphasis
was not on the animal and people shared
traits but rather on animals as products
and alienation creatures were construed
as vessels of disenchanted things cow
bodies contain beef cattle candles and
leathers sheep bodies mutton milk and
yarn in this way the living animal cow
sheep pig goat chicken is a living
carcass and it and it is viewed and it
is viewed that way even while it is
alive as being sort of the before stage
to its end state and I could give you
many examples of this may be the richest
and I'm going to be really really quick
obviously we could spend a whole time
just you know doing a semiotic analysis
of these really rich visual sources but
I think this gives you some sense of
this alienation where you have different
kinds of creatures all mixed up together
and there I mean there's
much of their subjectivity on display
and even in the still lives that contain
game animals i would argue that some of
the subjectivity is still there that the
depiction of just the boar head you can
sort of see the living breathing active
boar even in a composition where he is
dead so very quick analysis over a much
more complicated point so now we are
going to fully understand the episode
with which I started we need to move to
South America and I want to talk about
taming practices there so the we've
heard a lot of really interesting things
about differences between domestication
and taming which I'm grateful for so I
don't need I can go over this fairly
quickly but the edit category category
here would be taming or again in the
vocabulary of contemporary
anthropologists familiarization and this
is where indigenous peoples across
lowland south america and the caribbean
would take an animal from the wild and
tame them these were not bred in
captivity the reproduction was not
controlled but i think even more
interesting is that um actually the the
emek category that should say I magnetic
and the example I have is that of the
egg which comes from the carib language
group and examples from the 17th century
and up to contemporary ethnographies and
some of the characteristics of the egg
is that it's a trance pcs category could
also be used to talk about an adopted
child or a kidnapped child as well as a
tamed animal the candidates who are
eligible for eating are also eligible
for taming zand this way it's very
different than the European pet though I
do suggest that the genesis of the
European pet my toe something to the e
eggs and egg historically predates the
pet but once tamed eating is prescribed
taming is also gendered female work and
as is as is the case with a newborn
infant subjectivity is endowed as part
of the process of taming and so to
illustrate
in a hopefully quick and efficient way
I'll show you some visuals from this
amazing 16th century late 16th century
anonymous manuscript the swagman that it
is and also known as the Drake
manuscript and so here we have some
depictions of people capturing parrots
and parrots and monkeys are probably the
most obvious examples of egg but in
places where there's a lot of faunal
diversity a huge range of species are
found so I appreciate this image because
it shows the symmetry between the egg
and the hunted prey that the either
outcome as possible um sort of
contingent which is going to be the
product and here we have a domestic
scene where you have egg hanging out you
know the monkey here and the pair over
here and finally from western Amazonia a
depiction of amazonian women with her
tamed monkey and parrot and we see that
the sort of gendered associations quite
clearly in this depiction here's a
European trade Europeans get brought
into the system they're very keen on
getting parrots and monkeys and so as I
was doing research on this at first I
thought I was the first one to discover
this phenomena but it turns out that
anthropologist since the 19th century
have been aware of it there's a and
these are some of the anthropologists
who are working on it but the ethno
historical sources had not been
exploited so that's I think part of my
contribution here's the egg going back
to Europe this isn't a so that the place
where I want to end how much do I have
any time off okay so is to give you a
little thick description flavor of this
so one of my favorite accounts of this
phenomena comes from a Jesuit who spent
part of the early 18th century in
actually will in the Orinoco region he
was around here and he wrote although
there are no domestic animals among the
or enochians there are nevertheless
domesticated his ones who come to the
savage nation that they give a
particular name in order to distinguish
those that are wild and tame you know
here he's aware that this is an
ontological category for them among the
Indians there are always those animals
converted into domestic it's they seize
them in the forest for toys for their
children or in order to trade them with
other nations these animals tame by the
Indians are incredible and how tame and
manageable they come and of the many
species that he mentions one of them are
are these are peccaries and since
peccaries were identified by Europeans
as pigs on even though they're of it
they're not of the same family but they
share a sub order I thought it was it
would be maybe sensible to end by
talking about an instance of peccary
familiarization and this is from the
19th century missionary ethnographer
Everard bernard em third who lived among
the the way way and what is today jana
and he wrote he's one of the first
people actually did take systematic note
of this phenomenon 1882 article entitled
tame animals among the red men of
America and he singled out peccaries
noting quote that they become very tame
too much so sometimes for they follow
their master wherever he goes and
sometimes evens insists upon getting
into his hammock and I when I was
reading more about peccaries in
preparation for today I found out that
apparently within the first three days
of their life whoever is around they
will follow that creature for the rest
of their life so if it's a peccary it's
a peccary with the humans the humans
it's a dog it's a dog so you could see
where this kind of hammock sharing
behavior might originate from from that
point of view and so to come full circle
to our and possibly native northern
South American Indigenous man I see he's
his experience with these pigs is
actually bringing together at least
three different cultural systems he was
born I'm suggesting in a community where
this these kinds of taming Andy egg
practices were common he was then
exposed to European cultures of hunting
and then under brutal colonial
conditions he brought together them in a
sort of creative synthesis
and thank you very much all right well
first I want to thank you for organizing
fabulous conference and including me
because it's I've just gotten so much
out of this I'm just really grateful so
the title of my paper is actually not
the title in the in the program it's
memento mori Creole pigs is forest
phantasms on Hispaniola and this project
is really driven by oral history and and
including I have included a link on my
paper to a YouTube video of the first
anecdote that I start off with if you're
interested in seeing my backstage
process and some of my informants Goomer
seen those savala were accounted to me
the story of a harrowing trip home on
his motorcycle to the small central
frontier town of Monica Dominican
Republic where he lives like most
residents sabala is a small-scale
subsistence farmer who raises goats pigs
and cattle for living it was night and
he was on his motorcycle until he was
forced to stop due to a large felled
tree which had fallen across the road
upon which he saw aha Bali a feral boar
with long whiskers he grabbed his gun
just as the animal disappeared deciding
that it actually been Ibaka a spirit
demon prepared by someone for purposes
of sorcery these are people who've been
turned into animals the perplexing thing
about this story is that all the Creole
cobbly pigs on the island were
slaughtered at gunpoint by USAID in
nineteen seventy nine to nineteen
eighty-two due to fears of swine flu
threatening the u.s. pork industry I
argued that these apparitions oops I
forgot my powerpoint there we go I
argued that these apparitions invoke and
now vanished feral animal Commons which
was shared for centuries by the French
and Spanish colonies of Hispaniola
Island sandalman and south wing go which
became haiti and the dominican republic
lasting into the 20th century in the
dominican republic due to the late
arrival of sugar in the Eastern person
of the island in the Dominican Republic
the forest and the feral animals
remained largely
intact far later than in San domain
today Haiti and Cuba where intensive
sugar plantation economies caused its
demise by the mid 19th century feral
hunting economy this is ibaka a a boy
turning into a pig the fur off hunting
economy commenced in the 16th century
provisioning smoked meat to Corsairs
extensive cattle ranching of semi feral
herds later expanded in the Spanish East
providing meat and oxen to the thriving
plantation economy of Western Western
French colony until the 1780s when the
Haitian Revolution commenced the
thriving livestock trade links
Hispaniola and contraband ests to Cuba
Jamaica Venezuela Colombia coração in
Veracruz the forest cover provided a
free commons of wildlife and hardwoods
into the 20th century important
supplements to the subsistence economy
which sustained the rural poor outside
of unfree labor and the market economy
for centuries at a time when
dark-skinned could easily be read as a
sign of slave status for a Francisco
playo writing in the night 1890s the
true locus of Dominican identity was the
forest home of bores and dogs a black
pig sacrifice at the forest of guac I'm
on also commenced the Haitian Revolution
which freed the slaves and founded the
independent nation of Haiti signifying
freedom if the peg is a beloved
synecdoche for the forest Commons it is
not hard to see why which is precisely
why the beloved this precisely why the
USAID directed slaughter of all Creole
pegs on the island in 1982 was such a
calamity for the rural poor yet getting
at the effective significance of the
backwoods world of El Montay the
wilderness conjured up by the pig
however requires moving beyond the
Pharaoh livestock economy to consider
storytelling as a popular or archive the
broader cultural significance of the
Creole pig became apparent to me through
stories I was told of fantasmic pink
sightings of the Puerto criollo the Baja
is a changeling spirit a person which
has been transformed into an animal most
frequently appearing in the form of dogs
cattle cat or pigs but the pink stands
out since it's the only becau that is
beloved by car are classed together as
if as if they're embodied host is
entirely irrelevant this is not the case
here and the buckeye may be located on a
visceral continuum for the most
terrifying apparition which is the dog
to the most cherished which is the
Creole pig I wish to argue that the baka
pig narratives are haunting tales
conjuring a deep sense of loss and
nostalgia for Creole swine that helps us
discern a particular culture of intimacy
with the pig and its associated
emotional resonance the pigs rooting
behavior and its associations with the
underworld may explain its link to the
spirit world rendering the pre-opening
become more like a spirit double or
familiar than a demon thus
differentiating it from other baka
revenants these drinking tales about
shapeshifter baca's are commonly told by
plebeian men in the haitian dominican
frontier such as day laborers and
sentries butchers and cattle ranchers
for who much of their everyday life is
wrapped up with livestock especially in
the central Haitian Dominican Frontier
which was the front line of the 18th
century cattle trade to Haiti where
cattle and pigs have formed the basis of
the pastoral economy which until the 8th
set 1970s was more closely tied to the
Haitian cities of Ash and put a pass
than San flamingos one might say that
these porcine ghosts are archives of the
visionary and the expectant to quote
installer which reveal epistemic
anxieties and effective tremors traces
of trauma that have found no ready
outlet given the fact that the military
forcibly carried out the gun the
slaughter at gunpoint if I'm correct
these revenants get us closer to the
lived experience of the 1979 pink
slaughter on the island of Hispaniola
and the deep emotional attachment
smallholders felt to the patio pig which
was a junior member of the family and
the bedrock of the subsistence economy
these persistent pig apparitions should
thus be seen as a mode of popular
resistance to the erosion of everyday
life for the poor as has been argued for
African pastoralists whose livelihood is
intimately bound up with their animals
the significance of livestock in this
case is not merely economic in the
Caribbean pigs were a sign of the human
condition a constant everyday life live
presence in the patio as well as the
most prestigious food which should be
served at Christmas dinner and religious
feast days or on Sunday
a-and the primary object of sacrifice in
certain afro set afro Catholic rights
and volume trail pigs were indeed what
Marcel most would describe his total
social phenomena things which are which
contained all the threads through which
the social fabric is woven invariably
paired with cornmeal a sign of
indigeneity and ought oxen a the family
hog woods fed and cared for by mothers
and children and beloved as a food no
barnyard Beast conveys home in the
Caribbean like the pig does this is
nicely summed up in the Dominican
proverb of Puerto Cosima wrong sabinal
Pollock in case Alaska the wild pig
knows where he belongs unlike in Europe
where the pig has long been a sign of
incivility noting filth West and excess
the Caribbean pig the Kami does not
vilify pig and njoku sand songs they are
often cast as surrogate people and I
contributed as my as my Pig memento a
song about having sex with a Christmas
pig which is somewhere in the are in our
conference archive in which you can see
the substitution the scholarship on
animals hinges on the wild domestic
binary in ways that are problematic for
the case of Hispaniola the curl peg was
not a companion species in her ways
sense nor was recognition of their non
human personhood cause for suckling them
as in melanesia however practices such
as faith healing or laying on hands
which are used for both people in
livestock indicate what cone is
described as a trend species ecology of
selves well there was human pig
co-dependents and intimacy they were not
socialized into the world of humans as
we're fulani cattle or indian getty
guinea pigs well a pig or two was kept
around the house to eat leftovers and
food scraps as the offspring accumulated
they were left to roam in the forest yet
even the feral mountain pigs I have been
told came when called these practices
involving the taming of wild animals may
be a tie no legacy as Marty Norton has
argued which the Spanish adopted in the
early colonial period in The Fairly
economy of Hispaniola cattle and pigs
became contrastive signs of commodities
and gifts there appears to have been
early on a occupational specialization
within hunters with the term kanye
applied to the mounted cattle hunter and
chesa to that of hogs the latter
remaining important after cuddle hunting
declined after the Haitian Revolution
cattle became important transatlantic
commodities which were traded
internationally to regional Corsairs to
the sugar planters of San Lemang and
when when species was short which was
most of the colonial period cattle or
hides were swapped for slaves in the
Dominican Republic during slavery pigs
became a ubiquitous feature of the
conoco or evasion grounds since slaves
were rarely given me for slaves the
extraordinary fertility of pigs enabled
a steady protein source and ready cash
in times of need Rebecca Scott noted the
importance of obtaining farm animals as
slaves transeastern transition to
Friedman and pigs could serve as credit
for loans legal attests to the ubiquity
of pig and Barbados as well as the
animals enormous size and its distinctly
sweet taste because they were fed on
locust nuts plantains and fruit in
Jamaica they were fed Coco yams or taro
while in the intensive sugar producing
islands all meat became commodities on
Hispaniola this one's not the case for
pig the family pig became an exceptional
food highly prized their value accorded
not by their exchange value but rather
do their extension of hearth and home
while their offspring could be sold the
pig should ideally remain what Annette
winer has described as inalienable
possessions kept out of circulation
their paths tracing the social networks
of family and friends of all the animal
kingdom pigs may be physiologically the
closest to humans pig valves are used in
human replacements and scientists have
been studying harvesting pig organ
organs for human transplants current
xenotransplantation practice and
involved cloning and genetically
modifying pigs to make them more
compatible with the human immune system
the close proximity of pigs and humans
also makes them potential trans-species
disease transmitters which appears to be
one of the reasons why when swine flu
emerged in the u.s. in 1976 officials
panicked given the disease's resemblance
to the 1918 pandemic the most deadly flu
outbreak in world history in 1982 to
prevent the spread of classic flying flu
or hog cholera to the United States the
US government authorized USAID to
slaughter all crew
eggs on the island of hispaniola over
the course of 13 months the armies of
haiti and the dominican republic
ventured into the interior where they
butchered the pigs all mass countering
immense popular resistance with the
threat of a bayonet observers lamented
that it was the worst calamity ever to
befall the Haitian peasant since the
pigs was a central axis of the
subsistence economy the pig slaughter
signaled the beginnings of extreme food
precarity in both countries due to a
drop in the u.s. sugar quota with the
rise of high fructose corn syrup which
replaced sugar and processed foods both
nations shifted from traditional export
crops to tourism in the Dominican
Republic and export free trade zones but
in both countries assembling became the
most important source of employment
during the 1980s in Haiti the pink
slaughter was the tipping point
culminating in peasant suicides in an
exodus of refugees to the United States
in the Dominican Republic things also
went from bad to worse in nineteen set
in 1978 Antonio Guzman was elected in a
landslide but soon landed the nation in
a major corruption corruption scandal
which left covered the government
bankrupt just as oil prices spiked and
debt arrears forced them to turn to the
IMF for emergency loans resulting
stabilization measures sent food prices
skyrocketing at a time when wages had
sunk to some of the lowest in the
Caribbean in part to attract foreign
investment with bread riots eventually
erupting in South flamingo by 1982 the
pig slaughter catastrophe was hit the
central frontier particularly hard
because this was a small pig farmer belt
on the island or still the pig slaughter
arrived after a series of droughts which
left the population even more dependent
on live livestock than ever until then
creole pigs had been the mainstay of the
peasant subsistence economy the French
term mahone which became maroon for
runaway slave came from the Puerto
cimmaron wild pig which was the
primordial forest creature on both sides
of the island for pigs were extremely
well adapted to their environment
thriving on palm fronds worms and grubs
the disposed of household food remains
such as yoga and plantain peels their
excrement providing fertilizer for the
conoco and there and there rooting
loosening the soil for planting for an
initial cost of less than ten dollar
they're also offsprings could sell for
250 although caring for the animals in
the Monta was a male pastime the curio
Pig massacre became largely a women's
issue in large part because as some men
reported to me they concealed their pigs
from authorities in the mountains
whereas the family pig was harder to
hide Simone de Beauvoir has said that
women's animality is more manifest than
men's this may help explain why the pig
slaughter mobilised women on mass
perhaps it is the pigs exuberant
fertility that genders them female or
women's labor caring for the family pig
that renders the sow contiguous with
domesticity itself the close proximity
of pigs and humans can even extend to
pollution taboos such as beliefs in
Portugal that menstruating women can
spoil sausage made during the matanza
and in Japan it said that wild boars
prefer a pregnant woman's fields and
shapeshifter boars can turn into one's
mother and in Haiti it is the wrathful
goddess of love as a lead on tour
requires a creole paid for her sacrifice
yet irrespective of the popular
prohibition against killing South
especially the pregnant and their
offspring which are taboo to eat and
it's said to make you sick these were
also killed in the slaughter a fact that
outraged owners the family pig like the
Indian guinea pig is gendered female
along several axes since its associated
with fertility reproduction the ghosts
of the ancestors and the spirit of the
gift during the swine flu flu slaughter
women may have become particularly irate
because they had fewer other options for
generating cash than their menfolk and
we're more dependent on their pigs then
than men because of the nature of the
metro focal family in the Caribbean
women of course we're also the primary
caretakers for the family hogs lived off
off the family leftovers in their
pitiful complaints to the authorities
they wrote we are women who sustained
our families from production we're now
destitute outraged at the government's
order some women prefer to kill and eat
their own pigs rather than hand them
over to the troops irate protests as
protests flew in float in via telegram
and petitions in one letter signed by
102 claimants from a humble section of
kimani a full third where women which is
very high when you
consider that women don't in the
Dominican Republic play very leading
role in civil society this is all the
government campaign to explain the
rationale of the slaughter and and to
eat pork was aired on women's radio
programs interestingly while official
correspondence used the term matanza
massacre for this order officials we
frequently described it as a sacrificial
they ser dos a term which rationalized
the violence since ritual slaughter is
of course legitimate to add insult to
injury in an act of colossal bad taste
the Secretary of Agriculture hosted a
seminar on african swine fever at an
elegant colonial hotel in Santa mega
where they served imported whiskey and
ham cheese caviar canapes and bacon
wrapped meat tapas the Baja is a spirit
and animal guys this dual identity
corresponds with the close relationship
between pigs in the spirit world in
Congo culture of Central Africa in
central Africa the vaca pygmies were
renowned for their skills and felling
the most prestigious of game animals the
elephant however they they relied far
more upon the similarly tusked red bush
hogs as an everyday protein source
hunters must have visionary powers since
they are said to walk with the game
spirits one pursuing game indeed hunters
have privileged access to the spirit
world since the first harbours both
human and animal souls and banned
communities are often said to be linked
not only by family ties but co
guardianship of the tutelary spirits of
the dead and the forest is seen as both
reciprocating parent and ancestor
spectral pigs also form of central part
of central african male initiation
ceremonies in to secret societies and
their sacrifice is key to activating
certain certain spells which are in
newquay see which are embedded with
white clay a substance marking the
threshold between the living and the
dead the family pig is anomalous because
it is an animal that is part of the
family which according to Mary Douglas
would render the Beast taboo of course
even in the barnyard context pigs are
anomalous because they share human food
yet they also eat feces they're
associated with both life and death the
paragon of exuberant fertility while
eating subterranean roots
the vest delve into the underground
realm of beings where the dead reside as
Rene Girard explained the paradox which
is the essence of sacrifice because the
victim is sacred it is criminal to kill
him but the victim is sacred only
because he is killed as he continues in
acts of sacrifice the animal is a human
surrogate because from the animal realm
were chosen as victims those who were
the most human in nature this may
explain the unusual fact that a cemetery
was fashioned for the pigs murdered at
the hands of the army pigs are the brunt
of much rough teasing as in the
permitted disrespect of classic joking
relationships that Radcliffe Brown
described as those marking intimacy
appropriate okay appropriately then the
most popular character in Dominican
carnival is the late shown oops oops oh
did I pass my uh I guess you already saw
it is the late shown which is which has
become a national symbol of Dominican
identity it's a trickster figure with a
porcine face clothing color colorful
rags who carries a pig bladder with
which here it whips children as spirit
doubles these porcine baka revenants
appear to have emerged during the food
crisis developed right after the creole
pig slaughter in the 1980s as reagan's
caribbean basin initiative intended to
transform the caribbean from a
subsistence economy into a source of
cheap labor as haitian labor was
supposed to shift into export free trade
zones in the capital lower tariffs
imposed by the you IMF shock treatment
eventually displaced haitian staple
foods and hate as Haiti the poorest
country in the Western Hemisphere became
the largest net food importer in Latin
America given the dramatic erosion in
food security since 1982 it should not
come a surprise that the Creole peg
continues to haunt the border a poignant
reminder of better days for the campesi
novel I've not yet met one person who
would admit to purchasing a white us
replacement Pig although I have been
told that these paradoxically this is
interesting we're much more difficult to
handle than the monza or gentle Hubble
II indeed I was told that the
viciousness of these gringo pigs they
would eat your child alive
whew let's you had to watch them
constantly indeed these tales of gringo
man eating pigs bear an uncanny
resemblance to the vicious attack dogs
brought in to hunt down runaway slaves
and and ravage them during the Haitian
Revolution a very different animal than
the beloved family Sal but also seen his
eggs agenus so now we must return to the
vexatious question of why the Creole pig
continues to haunt the border in tales
of male bravado by men like Sibella
perhaps this vengeful revenant is bitter
because there are no more pigs to
appease the dangerous petrol spirits of
the dead and of course are their
preferred sacrifice the pigs may have
blanched to grey the pallid color of
phantoms and disease as they became
symbols of Imperial extraction since the
US was of course behind the slaughter or
perhaps the brutal mass slaughter at the
hands of the army which should have been
instead it carefully executed ritual
sacrifice for the gods morphed at the
hearty piebald creole pegs into men
eating grave robbing spectral cochon
place grey pigs the name of a notorious
secret site in haiti just as an act of
sacrifice transforms the Maleficent into
the benefice sent this is rene girard
this acted the exact obverse as the
surrogate victim met its death and
became the monstrous double zora neale
hurston describes her visit to the
terrifying social increase in
port-au-prince okay two sentences where
instead of the devotional
chromolithograph sin the altar she saw a
large black stone with a chain to it
reputed to be shape-shifter cannibals
the cochon grace have been seen at
market with human fingernails instead of
pigs feet since the cruel pig slaughter
turned an icon a family comfort mint
into one of death no wonder that these
feral holly's continue to haunt the
border returning with the rage and
despair that is all too characteristic
of the goddess Rizzoli who loves who
loved her croissant Creole I'm gonna
leave it at that cut off my lap while
you